the honeydew with ryan sickler no i see
my dad beat the
[ __ ] out of my mom and i see my mom [ __ ]
my dad oh my mom knocked
my dad out unconscious many times manny
bro my mom is [ __ ] she's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
sister she's like a little rosie perez
but she'll [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of
you
and that's how i grew up like people
like hold the [ __ ] door open how did
she knock them out what do you
smash them in the face punch them in the
face and try to run over the
they were wild kids you know but me
growing up i just go oh they're fighting
she's falling x-men [ __ ] play [ __ ]
sega dad your dad's got a glass jaw
oh [ __ ] get out of here no no my dad
beat the [ __ ] out of her too
jesus yeah uh the last time i remember
when they broke up
the so they were never married no they
they broke up my dad was 23. my dad was
21
probably they were [ __ ] kids you know
what i'm saying yeah um
but i walked in and my dad was beating
the [ __ ] out of my mom with his belt
and they were both naked and i was like
what the [ __ ] is happening
i was a little kid that might have been
the one time he wasn't beating the [ __ ]
that might have been the one time your
mom was actually asking for
curricular [ __ ] they were doing no no no
that's not what it was
oh [ __ ] jesus christ man oh
no then he started punching her in the
face right
and then i jumped on her i was like hey
knock it off and my dad started crying
wait you jumped in the middle of your
well
and they broke up that day that was it
because you could have gone the other
way
i mean dude people my whole life right
now you can be naked in some bedroom
beating somebody
right now i could be doing this with a
kid running it
your son running in i'm telling you i'll
never forget that [ __ ] that was
that is
[Music]
god
[Music]
you